Netflix puts billions of dollars into
new content every year but while
everyone hears about buzzy releases like
orange is the new black and house of
cards the sheer amount of content means
other shows get lost in the shuffle to
help out here are a bunch of upcoming
Netflix originals that are going to blow
you away
disjointed Kathy Bates is getting high
for disjointed a comedy in which he
stars as Ruth a woman whose life longer
mission has been to decriminalized
marijuana the series finds Ruth running
a Los Angeles area marijuana dispensary
and finding that business is much much
harder when you're stoned disjointed
which released a teaser on 4/20 will
premiere of 20 episode first season on
August 25th
David Java Baum of The Daily Show
co-created the comedy alongside Chuck
Lorre and a strong supporting cast two
rounds out the ensemble hold the dark
adapted from the william ii roldy 2014
novel of the same name
hold the dark focuses on the pursuit of
a wolf responsible for killing children
in the alaskan wilderness and the stars
alexander skarsgård and the west world's
jeffrey wright hold the dark comes from
director jeremy Sonier the man behind
the critically acclaimed thriller green
room while hold the dark doesn't yet
have a release date it started
production in early 2017
so hopefully sony will be back to
terrify viewers soon
green eggs and ham Netflix's adaptation
of dr.seuss is green eggs and ham will
follow the books characters guy and sam
as they take a road trip to save an
endangered animal along the way they
learn about friendship and of course
green eggs and ham Ellen DeGeneres's
attachment as an executive producer is
already a great sign for green eggs and
ham
which despite the books popularity has
yet to be adapted into a film or TV
series aside from the 1973 special dr.
Seuss on the loose Netflix have stayed
pretty quiet about the show since green
lighting in 2015 but to their website
notes that it's 13 episode first season
is expected to debut in 2018 the
Irishman with an estimated budget of
over a hundred million dollars the
Irishman is one of Netflix's priciest
upcoming projects but one that's
definite
worth the price it reunites Martin
Scorsese with Robert De Niro along with
a rumored supporting cast of heavy
hitters like Al Pacino Joe Pesci and
Harvey Keitel the Irishman stars DeNiro
as Frank the Irishman tearin' the mob
hitman allegedly responsible for the
death of Jimmy Hoffa
it's about Hoffa it basically is a guy
confesses that he had killed her firm
with a huge amount of talent on both
sides of the camera this movie will
surely be on your radar and in your
queue soon lost in space Netflix are
setting out to remake the popular 1960
series lost in space you know this one
cracked over here come on let's go take
a look
danger Will Robinson danger the show
will follow a new cast on the spaceship
Jupiter 2 which has stranded light-years
away from its original destination after
a crash cast member Toby Stephens calls
it a very clever modern reworking of the
original show's story the 10 episode
reboot had expected out in 2018 little
evil this horror comedy stars Adam Scott
and Evangeline Lilly as a newly married
couple with a son who just might be the
Antichrist in addition to a fun premise
on the great cast
little evil has some impressive people
working behind the scenes with Tucker
and Dale vs. evil writer director Eli
Craig once again pulling double-duty for
his first feature since that 2010 cult
hit the movie is expected to debut in
2017 mute hold the dark isn't Alexander
Skarsgard only upcoming Netflix film
he'll also star in mute skarsgård plays
Leo immutable tender living in a
near-future Berlin who involved on a
mission through the city's seedy
underbelly to try and find his missing
girlfriend mutants the second film in a
sci-fi trilogy from director Duncan
Jones who saves it's set in the same
universe as his 2009 called favorite
moon Jones says he plans to mute to
imagine Berlin the way Blade Runner
depicted Los Angeles just one more
reason it will definitely be one to
watch when it debuts later this year
game over man the workaholics gang will
reunite for game over man an action
comedy featuring Blake Anderson
and as home and Adam diviners three
friends on the verge of getting their
video game financed when their
benefactor is taken hostage by
terrorists Seth Rogen is said to produce
a film alongside his writing partner
Evan Goldberg and Kyle Neuer check the
co-creator of workaholics will directed
based on a script from Anders home I owe
this sci-fi movie tells the story of
some world a teen who finds herself one
of the few survivors on a
post-apocalyptic earth Sam is played by
the nice guys Margaret quale
and Anthony Mackie who you're recognize
of the Avengers Falcon co-stars as Micah
a fellow refugee on his way to the last
human shuttle leaving Earth Danny Huston
recently spotted in DC's Wonder Woman
will also appear in an undisclosed role
there's no word yet on when the movie
will premiere although filming took
place in late 2016
so hopefully IO will be here to get all
our hearts racing soon big mouth Netflix
is upcoming animated comedy big mouth
follows chameleon Nick crawls time as an
awkward teenager growing up with his
best friend Andrew Goldberg now a writer
and the producer for Family Guy Kroll
voices himself with fellow stand-up John
Mulaney playing Goldberg Kroll calls to
show over 30 years in the making and
he's clearly using his comedy
connections to round out the cast he's
recruited an impressive roster that
includes Maya Rudolph Jordan Peele Fred
Armisen and Jenny slate the series is
expected out in 2017 Gerald's game there
are about a billion Stephen King
adaptations and the works and the
Netflix is joining the arena where the
Gerald's game starring watchman's carla
Gugino as a woman stranded in her
lakeside home after a sex game gone
wrong
Gerald's game doesn't have a release
date yet but its boasts an accomplished
horror director in Mike Flanagan
Flanagan also has Kings full support
Gugino has said that King was a big fan
of Flanigan's hush and gave him his
blessing in pursuing the project King is
also apparently pretty happy with the
early curve
tweeting in February of this year that
the movie is horrifying
hypnotic terrific 1922 another Stephen
King adaptation in the works of Netflix
1922
as an actor familiar with the bestseller
author's work Thomas Jane who led the
2003 film adaptation of Kings
dreamcatcher and the 2007 adaptation of
the mist Jane plays Wilfred James a man
who admits to killing his wife with the
help of his teenage son after her death
he starts to believe that she is
haunting him altered carbon based on the
2002 novel by Richard K Morgan also
carbon focuses on Takeshi Kovacs a
former elite warrior who's been
imprisoned for 500 years before his mind
is downloaded into someone else's body
to solve a murder Suicide Squad star
Joel Kinnaman will take on the role of
Kovacs starring opposite Kristen Lehmann
and James Purefoy thanks for watching
click the loop icons or subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love thing
[Music]